(ambient music)
- [Voiceover] I was
raised by a single mom.
Lately, I've been thinking
about how I'll move out
one day and I get so upset.
I love her more than anything,
and I can't imagine leaving her all alone.
- [Voiceover] I was raised by
a single mom and four sisters.
They never stressed about
teaching me to be a real man,
but they did value me being a good person.
And ya know what, I'm
proud of the man I am.
- [Voiceover] My dad is a single parent.
Mom left us when I was a baby.
But you know what? I really am fortunate.
My dad is so inspiring.
He's tough and caring.
He's taught me what it truly
means to be an amazing parent.
- [Voiceover] Grew up with a single mom.
She teaches us to cook and work on cars.
We call her Wonder Woman and she loves it.
- [Voiceover] My dad is
the best part of my life.
Alone, he's raising my baby sister and I,
all while serving 10
plus years in the Navy.
He's just the best.
- [Voiceover] My dad has had a hard life
and is still the kindest man I know.
One day soon, I have to provide
him with a life he deserves.
It is my biggest goal.
- [Voiceover] My mom is a single parent
who took care of us kids while
working and going to college.
I can't think of a better
example of a hero than her.
(upbeat music)